[Musique]
il y a des pièces qui vous bousculent
alors moi j'aime le primate parce qu'il
a ce regard qui est
qu'on pourrait dire si proche de nous et
son attitude donc mais on vit avec la
pièce moi je vis avec du matin en soir
quand je vais me coucher quand je me
réveille la nuit c'est OK comment je
vais travailler cette zone là comment je
vais m'en sortir aux toilettes ou la
douche il y a pas de il y a peu de temps
de répit mais c'est que du c'est que des
instants
assez magique et puissant parce que on
est tout le temps dans la recherche
le regard est percutant une véritable
claque pour dénoncer la menace des
espèces à la vie à la mort
pour l'histoire parce que le gorille en
captivité il a ce côté où il peut pas
regarder l'humain ils s'en détournent
alors dans la nature c'est on dit
toujours aux humains ne regardez jamais
un gris dans les yeux donc j'aimais
l'histoire mais j'aimais pas le point de
vue que ça donnait à la pièce et la
pièce il faut qu'on puisse tourner
autour et qu'on capte son regard à tous
les endroits
le sculpteur mais comme tous les
artistes on est un peu fétichiste de des
objets et un peintre va sans t'avoir 50
pinceaux il va en utiliser 4 et moi j'ai
je sais pas 50 60 outils et généralement
j'en utilise 5 à 6
moi sur des pièces de cette taille là je
commence au bâton
parce que le bâton il permet de tasser
la terre de l'accrocher sur le grillage
il permet de donner du rythme aussi moi
je joue beaucoup avec les rythmes que ça
peut que ça peut renvoyer dans une
dynamique de poils
Pierre-Jean Chabert aime le contact la
matière petit il utilise fil de fer et
bougies pour laisser vaguer son
imagination en grandissant le travail de
la terre de l'argile lui procure les
plus belles émotions dont le monde du
travail loin des aspirations artistiques
Pierre-Jean n'est pas heureux il décide
alors de suivre les cours du soir à
l'école du Perret à Paris
en 2013 il s'installe en Touraine et
rejoint les ateliers de la Morinerie à
Saint-Pierre-des-Corps il se forme alors
au moulage et à la soudure et se lance
dans la sculpture animalière
on m'a dit donc tu es courageux à
l'époque je me disais dans tes plutôt
fou quoi c'est c'est insensé c'est mais
c'est un rêve un rêve d'enfant
j'ai eu envie de me confronter à lui et
puis j'ai envie de faire une une période
de grosse pièce parce que finalement on
est on est si petit puis on essaie aussi
de ce jauger de se dire ce que est-ce
que je peux y arriver est-ce que est-ce
que finalement la pièce elle aura autant
d'impact que celle qui est en petit
format
c'est un peu tout le challenge le
modelage du primate finit en terre une
sculpture de Bron sera couler et
proposée aux collectionneurs
Pierre-Jean Chabert ou quand le vivant
rencontre le figé